hey guys Doug Walker here welcome to the
premiere of demo real I just want to
give you a little information about the
show on how it's gonna work I'm like
nostalgic Rick that was everyone week
this is going to be every two weeks
because it takes a little bit more time
because it's more than just a guy in
front of a white wall uh so it is gonna
be every two weeks however every other
week there's always going to be
something demo reel related whether it
be a short or a trailer for the next one
there's always gonna be something so
every time you show up on Tuesday on
that Kappa glasses comm you're always
going to see something related to demo
reel on top of that like I said before
we have a talk show that's gonna be
coming out with me we got game shows we
have all sorts of things coming up for
you guys that were in the process of
getting out to you so stay tuned a lot
more is coming I hope you enjoy what we
got
so cool it's been a rough day hasn't it
yes dr. Bruce Willis and now you're
gonna tell me your dirty little secret
aren't you
and what is your dirty little secret
walking around like record
they don't know that well that's okay
that's just a 700 club no I mean I see
ghosts
really
they're everywhere there's even one
behind you good good
Jesus it's beetlejuice I'm the ghost of
the Loews Biddy your soul had for defin
you I'm a talkin II oh my god ghost dad
that's right now about jell-o pudding
pop from the fiery deaths of hay the
only thing we can do
who are you going to call ghostbusters
who are you ghostbusters
Chicago division but we're in
Philadelphia we're branching out
alright ghosts prepare to die again you
can't do this to me I gave you
malcolm-jamal fire
can I try
get him to keep it go what we chose a
date to move it and they're scary too
this is your good old friend Randy thing
- oh hello I'm Donny Dubray and what you
just saw believe it or not was not the
success I know it felt like the movie
looked like the movie maybe even a
little better than you remember but in
fact this was a film brought to you by
our online production team demo reel
what is demo reel well how do I put it
you got moved is old and new low-budget
a big-budget appealing to all sorts of
different audiences and as great as all
these movies are in all humbleness we
can do it better and I don't think I'm
being too selfish when I say that we
have perfected what many consider to
already be perfect and made it even more
perfect
we vowed to show what our cinematic
skills are capable of and there is no
doubt that we have quite a wide range of
talent including directors actresses
directors writers directors
cinematographers directors caterers and
writer cinematographer director actress
caterers
our goal to reach an audience so large
that Hollywood would have no choice but
to offer us a chance to make our very
own motion picture we even send our
motion pictures to the original
filmmakers themselves in fact famed
director M night Shyamalan one set of
our work I thought my twists were bad
yes see even he had to acknowledge that
our work was so good that his was
inferior by comparison with Rebecca
stone Tacoma Narrows Carl Copenhagen and
the rest we want to make our incredibly
humble goal of fame fortune and riches
beyond our wildest dreams come true for
you demo reel
we don't make films we remake them God
all right now six cents seemed to go
over really well online in fact a lot of
people say was our best work to date I
know did you see that one comment what
the hell did I just watch
people are speechless we're leaving them
asking questions important questions
like what the hell did I just watch
exactly so I feel for the next one we
should do something supernatural Tacoma
what he got well I was thinking
hoovering Heights there's a lot of
atmosphere as well as ghosts in the
movie and it'll give us a chance to
really dive into the psychological hey
hey or Batman Oh Batman would be awesome
yeah let's do better uh I don't think
Batman is really supernatural
sorry it's always flying around sucking
people's blood
that's Dracula no no no it was
definitely Penman yeah I remember
Francis Ford Coppola talked about on his
commentary that was also Dracula it is
your obsession with dragon I don't have
enough look
Bevin's not a vampire are you saying
that George Clooney is not a blood
sucking Nosferatu who feeds on the young
to keep himself immortal
I cannot argue with that there you go my
name is Tacoma Narrows I am the writer
for Demery I came across Donnie and I
thought what better way to break into
the industry true a lot of times he
doesn't go with my ideas in fact when I
originally put down as almost nothing to
do with the final product
but that's Donnie's direction and I
respect him as an artist hey this this
isn't what I wrote oh come on it's
better that way how is it better this
way it's more engaging William Wallace
is supposed to be having an epic battle
with the British well now he's having an
epic battle with the dragon named
Longshanks what did I leave off respect
is such a strong word my name is Rebecca
stone that's stone not stone a the
accent was silent I went to college for
acting after college I decided to do my
own one-woman show which was of course
Hamlet and I know what you're thinking
how can a woman play Hamlet well I
always thought that Hamlet seemed like a
woman trapped inside of a man's body so
I decided to play his feminine side you
know that one scene where he's talking
to the skull and he's like oh poor dead
jester guy I reload a little bit your
bony lips I have kissed I know not
see him kissing a guy suddenly makes
sense it's a lot better than that weird
gesture boy thing that they were
implying I don't know Shakespeare's a
perv
I'm currently a security guard at a
warehouse in the greater Chicagoland
area I'm not allowed to say which one
but they have been extremely good to me
one of them said I was a student which I
assume is Italian for bright we have a
mutual agreement between us we film here
and they do whatever they do back there
they don't ask questions and we don't
ask questions the mobile polling with
the morning yes the good night Bobby
what do these people do again
construction oh all right so you're
gonna enter through this right here so
which of the Batman movies were you
thinking about doing well I don't like
to think small big Shaq so I was
thinking about doing but Christopher
Nolan movies which one all of them uh
how do you do all of the Christopher
Nolan movies oh no I see where he's
going with this like that and West
Batman movie where all the villains come
together and trying to take him out
exactly except with more sharks wait let
me get this straight you want me to
write a script combining all the
Christopher Nolan movies into one story
with all the characters in all the plot
twists exactly we can put it all in one
movie everyone's always like oh let's
put um in one movie at a time don't just
shove them all together it'll be great
but most people came and follow one
Christopher Nolan movie without using a
flow chart don't you think that's going
to be a little much yeah that's the
American Way too much too fast don't
think that's the America sure it is come
on ask Karl he says American his Uncle
Sam aren't you Carl yeah shit as
American as foosball and apple strudel
there you go then
guten tag my name is Takara Copenhagen
it's benign cameraman and a serious
demonic camera coming so I couldn't a
commie talk see it's my living yeah
Karl's a weird one
I think he's Cajun Russian hey he's
German he's always talking about before
zeevala bell but also phone fell I had
quite destroyed history unfortunately
all of that has been classified
therefore I will have to black out
certain questions myth man Schwartz Bell
I think he said he was in the German
Navy nein nein I think he told me he was
working for a lady named Stacy Chris
Dodd see I don't know they get relate
huh fell look says uneven my question
left how are you
none of your business he seems to be
really good friends with that other
cameraman Quinn I think he's Irish I'm
pretty sure he's Cajun - my assistant is
Quinn he did not flexors here and people
not to answer any of your questions my
name is Quinn and I didn't work for the
IRA and ain't gonna answer any questions
you get to me I think it's a good manner
as a fan I mean come on man I am dying
to pray the founder and director of demo
reel
we don't make a whole lot of money on it
in fact you could argue we're losing
money but you know you make sacrifices
for your art and that's what counts
outside of this I do not have a job
which I know is hard to believe so I
rely on my wife's income and I know what
you're thinking
Donny how is that fair to you well it's
not I mean you have no idea the stigma
that's placed on stay-at-home husbands
who made remakes of films with their
best friends
some might say I'm cheap or dodging
responsibility but I ask you this what
kind of guy wants to set the
means work liberation thingy years back
not me
I'm doing my wife a favor by allowing
her to work by giving her another spot
for a working woman to come in now
that's a sacrifice so I'm simply
allowing working women the chance to be
working women I'm part of the liberation
I'm there doing it for my sisters and if
you think that's dodging responsibility
well you're more than welcome to set the
women's liberation thingy back several
years so you're supporting your vibes
ability to support to you now see you
finally get it all right so we're on
board with the Nolan movies then I
yeah just one question can we go with
the Harvey Dent from the first Burton
Batman you know the one played by Billy
Dee Williams I kind of feel like you got
the shaft
you know replacing a charismatic black
man with that Texas tool for the
fugitive oh I see seeing what would
happen if you have Billy Dee Williams
play to face yes okay all right I like
that I like that a lot
it's like seeing lando calrissian play
both the good and the bad that's exactly
what Lando Calrissian did yeah whatever
just making the mayor of Cloud City
master Bruce saying is how both your
parents have been murdered it is my job
to serve you as your body but wait
isn't that a little confusing seeing as
how you're also my Butler I don't much
like your toe go to your room go to your
room yes master Bruce well so Alfred
after years and years of soul-searching
I finally decided the logical conclusion
what to do with my life I'm gonna be a
superhero okay that's it okay I didn't
have to convince you I've liftoff your
fortune for years now I've seen
prostitutes of every shape color
the way I see if you wanted to go and
shoot the Pope I'd be behind you never
give another me have--
never I will never give up on you and
neither will my problem of well-paid
whores we have much work to do my horny
old friend this calls for a costume
change like what something terrifying
all right Alfred you can turn around now
terrifying isn't it
no it's Mario why are you dressed like a
Mario brother Mario scares me it's time
the rest of the world shares my fear
nobody's friggin afraid of Mario why are
you afraid of Mario he's an Italian
plumber who steps on Turtles that's rude
and that he kicks him out of their shell
takes their hole in blood jizz them to
death with it
man's a psychotic I don't want that
person near my toy let's go try another
costume fine fine I'll find something
else that scares me
I am a creature of the night Waldo
you're afraid of Waldo
nobody can find him even with his red
and white striped shirt he always
appears to blend in don't get another
one okay who was never afraid of Santa
Claus next oh I was Buki which next next
I am spider-man Titan seriously yep
does he wear red too yep what are the
odds of two guys representing a spider
with a Colorado get another one
I mean seriously right well god I'm a
housing market correction my increase
foreclosure rates among homeowners will
lead to a crisis in subprime loans and
collateralized debt obligations you
either go and come up with something
right now or I will stab you in the eye
would you the only one just bats bats
see now that's something scary oh come
on
they're like number 50 on my scary list
yes do it all right if you think it's
scary
absolutely sure we don't want to go with
the plumber right I warned you
right in the eye all right all right
I'll go back
it's hard playing multiple roles
especially when you're the only female
here fortunately my background has
prepared me for this after I did my
one-woman Hamlet
I wrote a one-woman Titanic it's very
tricky to do a hot steamy love scene by
yourself
Oh Rose you're the most beautiful
seventeen year old going on thirty that
I've ever seen
Oh Jack you're the most beautiful
twenty-three year old going on twelve on
all the steerage want to set sail for my
pants Oh jack Oh Rose Oh Jack rose Jack
row Oh jack Oh Rose Oh Jack I can see
your heart
Oh jack they won't see my glove Batman
yeah I got why don't the other one
though if you're the couch I I don't my
glasses I had the black glove in the
black couch that's kind of difficult it
is quick I
yeah yeah cuz that looks exactly like
the best identical good Josh good trying
to help it
wow I don't even have glasses I can see
it's not the right one okay I do better
if I have my thinking hat okay so I had
the glove okay it screw the thinking hat
this is really that Batman can't only
have one glove
cuz it's freaking Batman why would he go
round with one claw what they could
identify his hand yeah hey that pan
looks very Bruce Wayne ish sir any way
we could write around the fact that
Batman only has one glove else wears one
glove Michael Jackson that's Michael
Jackson that could be a nice plot twist
and that that's good because you have
one black and one white hand but the
black hand is the gloved hand I have no
idea where I'm going with this this is a
stupidest idea you know we're just gonna
call one glove Batman that'll definitely
stick yeah there that glove bearded one
glove famine a new enemy seems to have
shown the people say
who is that high-pitch Commissioner
Gordon he's a bank robber dressed in all
white makeup simply known as the Joker
you wait yeah I guess you're right he's
just some clown
Wow we were wrong on that one yeah
note to self clowns are people we must
put our trust in Harvey Dent he's a good
politician with a strong personality how
do you know I saw Fred one of the
Joker's mentally disabled henchmen with
a gun in a toy that sounds like a very
mentally unstable person oh he's fine as
long she don't give anything in his face
kind of sensitive about that hey Rebecca
um can I ask you something yeah what
well I I don't know really at it ask
this what is it well um as a white
person does this offend you I mean am i
crossing any boundaries or anything cuz
what do you mean I just feel kind of
weird dressing up in white face and
frienship up in front of a bunch of
white people look if it makes you feel
any better we did just cast you as a
cream of wheat making servant who always
sides with his rich white master no
matter how insane he is you know what
you're right
you crackers had it coming you've seen
I'm not a monster
I'm just ahead of the curve
these good people are only as good as
the world wants them as when the chips
are down be civilized people will eat
each other let's delve into this a
little further by examining the works of
Friedrich Nietzsche wait a minute why am
i chit-chatting with you you can't have
two people yeah I was wondering that
myself
you can take nothing away from oh I'm
making a coffee run you guys want
anything good degrees two sugars it's
okay I'll tell you where they are both
of them even though we clearly
established that there's no clocks in
here I'll rig it so that you can only
reach one up in time are you so sure
only I'll reach one of them in time not
the cops I saw you had a better GPS it
counts for traffic and even updates the
street names so which one you going for
Rachel really who cares that the only
hope for Gotham is about to be burned
I want notary
well it looks like this is the end on't
worry my dear I'm a man of few words
count soul our actions one week down the
news and shed light of the law that nest
of vipers
is it wrong to say that even though
we're about to die your voice just made
me orgasm right now if it is I don't
want to be right Batman what Oh for
crying out loud really you saved him
instead of me it's not what you think
honey no I got it
clearly he means more to you than me no
no I swear that's not it business first
I understand hey Harvey you want to know
who Batman truly is you don't hear that
probably the only man in Gotham who can
afford to be bad his name begins with a
c'
Oh for god sake where are those cops how
come they never update the street names
this used to be 88 and now it's the
Reagan Parkway isn't there any other
landmark that points us in the right
direction oh there it is